hey guys welcome back to the show at the
end of this video I'm gonna be showing
you an exclusive clip from an interview
I did with rebel wisdom we both
investigated the London real saga and
finally we decided look we need to sit
down have a conversation about this
whole thing unpack it talk about the
anonymous sources who've contacted us
talk about everything and so I've got a
little clip of that and rebel wisdoms
gonna post the full interview on his
site tomorrow so check for that tomorrow
morning but before we get to that before
we do that I want to talk about the
breakdown because we don't talk about it
that much in the interview itself and I
feel like it it's highly contextual to
this whole thing you have to understand
what happen because the posts have been
since delete it's like the post from
Saturday the breakdown the meltdown
whatever you want to call it it's all
been erased
and it's important before going into
that interview that you know sort of
what happened because we kind of discuss
it but we don't go fully in depth of
what had happened so I'm gonna give that
to you now as I said you cannot find
this anywhere else because it was all
deleted but luckily I took some
screenshots so Saturday letting real
post to his community tab where he
basically says you know did this is the
digital freedom platform explained you
know I've been under a lot of criticism
there are a lot of trolls and I'm not
gonna read the whole thing but basically
here are the highlights right here he
says that he he won't have you telling
him or his supporters what to do he
won't have it especially not on his
social channels which are literally his
house ok let's start with the fact that
they're not literally his house and that
it's a bit ironic that the person you
know who's running the digital freedom
platform would be so sensitive about
what people say to him in his house but
moving on he then says he's gonna use
these funds as frugally as possible but
that doesn't make a lot of sense because
if you wanted to be frugal you could
have just used an existing platform like
I don't know it shoots like these
platforms that have already existed that
already do the thing you say that you're
the first to do the very first digital
freedom platform but ok maybe we can
give him the benefit of the doubt there
where it gets really crazy is where he
says you know if I wanted to simply make
an extra 1 million dollars that I would
sell 330 of my business accelerator
programs at $3,000 each which I did last
month so I surely don't need to Ray
donations to do this law so a problem
here which is if you didn't need to
raise donations to do this why did you
raise donations to do this if what
people are saying about you is that
you're milking money from your
subscribers for no reason and then you
say I didn't need to raise money from my
subscribers to do this you're kind of
proving the point even goes on to say
the point of this platform is the
collective effort that is exponentially
stronger than one person but it's all
owned by Brian it's it's not owned by
the collective it's owned by Brian it's
his company at the end of the day it's
just London real 2.0 I mean I don't know
what this is talking about and if you
really could have just sold your
accelerator why didn't you this is this
gets more confusing by the second you
just keep going on you're more confused
he then says it's not his job to respond
to critics even though he's responding
to critics and then says he's gonna be
focused on winning now obviously it's a
horrible take and so he got started
getting ripped apart in the comment
section and instead of sort of taking it
on the chin he decides that he's gonna
fire back at the people who basically
built this platform and donated money so
I'm gonna read off a few comments and
his response so this guy says where's
the David Icke QA that was advertised to
be posted was it a lie will it be
delivered apparently something was
promised lenden real response by not
answering the question saying did you
donate thought not you're gonna notice a
recurring pattern here this person says
you've literally said nothing at all you
didn't explain anything except to say I
know what I'm doing I'll spend the money
don't ask what I do with the money
because startups in tech if it was that
easy to sell 330 of your 3,000 buy
courses then why not just do it and find
your platform yourself instead of
begging for people's hard-earned money
good point is Brian gonna answer that
question I don't have to explain
anything
read it again okay a fool and his money
are easily parted just saying suckers
London real let me guess he didn't
donate Louis 496 says yeah I don't trust
you anymore London real clapped back
it's mutual let me guess you didn't
donate so I really don't care at this
point I was a little concerned I was
like what's going on is this some intern
hijacking the account but
we'll come back to that in a second this
person says elderly narcissist and
plenty of real response who you callin
old was amazing because he doesn't
respond to the narcissist thing he
doesn't think issue with that
it's just who are you calling old hey
Brian just doesn't want to be cool at
all that's the only thing and it just
continues like this like comment after
comment he's just going off on his
subscribers the people who gave him
money
I mean what's crazy is that person I
read you off earlier he was asking
questions about the David Icke thing and
Brian Rowe said hey you let me guess you
didn't donate turns out that guy
actually did donate and he says I can
show you proof he says please into the
question and not insult people that gave
you money shocking does Brian respond to
that shockingly no so this person says
conspiracy theorists can see the
conspiracy and everything apart from the
one they are financing 100k to stream
some video behave yourself Brian the
real Brian Rowe says 1.3 million people
people dummy yes it costs money let me
guess you didn't donate this guy
response and he says show the audit if
your aim is transparency to which brian
says transparency was never my aim dummy
the money was entrusted for me to spend
as I see fit and I will go find another
place to troll I don't even know what's
worse here is it the arrogance is it the
the passive-aggressive comment I I don't
know what's funny about this is that two
days later after he's deleted all this
what does Brian say and again my plan is
to be as transparent with you as
possible hopefully talk about some of
the questions and some of the
misunderstandings that have been kind of
flying around out there and hopefully
give you some clarity Brian all right
well that's basically it all that's
really left to say is I hope you guys
have enjoyed the Brian Rose London real
series here's a teaser clip from the
rebel wisdom interview and I left a
little something special for you guys
who stick to the end well one thing is
that he said he was going to stop the
crowdfunding at a million and then he
started raid trying to raise another 250
thousand a month so an extra three
million and we want to get a hundred
thousand signatures of course you have
to give your email address to sign up
and
why that really so within that he's also
framing himself as like the whole thing
is centered on him like I am though I am
the only hope for free speech I've been
battling for free speech they've been
doing this to me it's all about me and
then he posted another one basically
basically criticizing his audience
saying losers focus on winners winners
focus on winning and then Brian rose
himself was in the comments arguing with
his own audience basically and will show
some of this basically saying you didn't
donate I guess you didn't donate and
this guy says scammers focus on scamming
and London real goes like you let me
guess you didn't donate here's another
one London real you are a controlled
idiot sorry if you don't see it you can
see some definitely areas where he just
went wrong where he's talking about head
faking his audience you can't do that to
an audience when you're raising a
million dollars you just can't you can't
tell them hey I'm having to lie to you
about certain things you can't tell them
that you're gonna build a digital
freedom platform but then like weeks
later say oh by the way I've been using
free platforms all along and you should
have known that and then not explain why
you're not just using the most obvious
free speech platform that there is you
can't say that you're gonna stop
fundraising and then keep on fundraising
under the name of this value that we all
hold so dear but then really not stand
up to scrutiny when it's question do you
really stand up for that value at all
[Music]
everyone likes me and thinks I'm great
at my digital freedom platform my
kitchen arena bad food people don't
judge me and haters don't need it my
freedom platform it's my house literally
fully proven don't receive doors nothing
but kindness
[Music]
space you know like
I didn't read a platform I digital
freedom platform look at you will see
very select crowd in my country war
they're all denying Kovan people that
support me next and when more people
that support me and donate terms and
conditions remove any content from the
website that it determines his offensive
that unlawful and threatening defamatory
obscene or otherwise objectionable at
which determination shall be at the sole
and absolute discretion of long as
delimited
[Music]
[Music]
Sakura
the car
[Music]